[Applause]
[Music]
the Islamic Republic of Iran
it's that country that makes it
independently these you claim to enjoy
this earth never actually watched this
country is also well known in a rather
different regard as being one of the
United States's main enemies as well as
being something of an antagonist in
Europe and in the Democratic world in
general Iran is an Islamic theocracy
where the head of state is not even a
politician but a religious leader the
Ayatollah Gemini
[Music]
their legal system is based on Sharia
law and torture and executions are
pretty common in the country Owen just
in case that wasn't enough the
government also funds several terrorist
groups all over the world important
liens this one called Hezbollah hold on
just a second because I mean the same is
true of Saudi Arabia nonetheless the
Saudis are a major ally of the United
States and have important commercial
relationships with the rest of the world
so why do Ron teen is bad while Saudi
Arabia is seen as good by some Western
governments many would believe that the
answer is a pretty simple one and that
would be oil but the truth is that Iran
has the fourth biggest oil reserves in
the world further their crude oil is
similar to that in Saudi Arabia
however just one year ago they had a fam
meaning that they couldn't sell it to
most of the world's countries yeah you
heard that right for years both America
and Europe didn't want to buy anything
that came from this country so now you
might be wondering why is Iran such a
threat to international security while
other countries and radicalism are being
better treated today we're going to
answer that question but first let's
take a look at the history
[Music]
[Applause]
the first Islamic Revolution till the
1970s Iran was one of the most glamorous
dictatorships in the world the so-called
Shah from Persia and our friend Mohammad
Reza Pahlavi ruled over the country with
an iron fist at the same time here in
his wife Farah diba were gossip magazine
star and yes I said our friend there
because the Shah of Persia with a great
ally for the United States as well as
the free world in general as we said a
moment ago Iran holds the fourth largest
oil reserves in the world last they have
over 18 million inhabitants and the
highly educated population when compared
to the neighboring countries further
Iran is a crucial spot for controlling
the Middle East region nonetheless while
the Shah was traveling all across the
world enjoying a lifestyle that would
make Kanye West look humble his country
was getting ready for a resolution and
the name I wonder what sort of
revolution might this be was it a
communist revolution or perhaps it was
an Islamic one well initially the
Iranian opposition was pretty varied
unlike Saudi Arabia Iran or as was known
before the Persian Empire had a long
history as well as a sophisticated
culture so among these opposition groups
you could find pro-western liberals
marxist social democrat and of course
radical isn't it
the latter just had one difference
compared to the others they had a leader
the Ayatollah Khomeini the fine living
in exile in Paris he had a great
charisma and a reputation among the
Iranian
son is pulpit in Paris can mainly
addressed all of these revolutionaries
in Iran encouraging them to take power
with the promise of a new and democratic
Iran and Iran where Marxist liberals and
Islamists could all live together and
this is how the Islamic Revolution was
born in November of 1979 revolutionary
forces took over the government Palace
and the US Embassy in Tehran this is
actually the basis of the movie Argo
starring Ben Affleck in this movie you
can see the story of the American
workers at the Embassy the taken hostage
by the Iranians right afterwards the
Ayatollah Khomeini would come back to
his country supported by all of his
believers and this is what he said
during his first speech there is no need
for an Islamic democracy it is enough
with Islam it was of course to eliminate
the other revolutionary groups that has
helped him take power all of those
Western liberals those Marxists those
Social Democrats and even moderate
Muslims were excluded from the new
Islamic Republic and of course the
country's relationship with the United
States was totally broken well actually
it was only kind of broken in a way we
could say that America and Iran went
from being friends soon being is
complicated
on one hand become any hate of the US
but on the other hand was Ronald Reagan
the American presidents as a sign with
selling weapons to the Iranians so they
could fight against their neighboring
country Iraq remember Saddam Hussein
well he was a common enemy for those
Canadians and Uncle Sam in 1997 the
Iranians chose a new president Mohammad
Khatami who tried to restore friendly
relationships with the US but at the
same time the supreme leader who was not
Khomeni anymore but this other one you
see on the screen the Ayatollah Khomeini
who had an evergreen obsession with
Israel so he was funding a terrorist
organization called Hezbollah now
there's a get that in Iran the ultimate
decision-maker is not the president but
this religious leader who holds the
position of head of state this said the
American President Bill Clinton said he
would never befriend a country that
doesn't want to Israel to exist
meanwhile Iran remained a divided
country despite the majority of their
population being okay with a radically
Islamic leadership there is still a big
secular movement in the state then in
2005 something happens that would change
the fate of Iran forever
what up Marty Richard supply water looks
like between the end of the 1990s and
the start of the new millennium
Iran had flirted with moderation and
even secularism they even passed a
divorce law that included separation of
goods between husband and wife not only
that but by the year 2006 50% of the
country students were female of course
Iran was still systemically violating
human rights women were forced to have
their heads covered and religious
minorities were forbidden but don't
forget we are talking about an Islamic
Republic in neighboring Saudi Arabia
women aren't even allowed to drive but
as you can imagine this little corner of
freedom had not so many fans on the
radical Islamic side of the spectrum
so the ayatollah khomeini used all his
power to radicalize the public opinion
against the president yes Amy and this
is how in 2005 this other guy with an
impossible to pronounce name won the
election Mahmoud Ahmadinejad this is how
a radical counter reform process started
in Iran tortures and detentions
increased significantly after this year
police chase down women you wouldn't
wear the hijab properly and the whole
world was shocked by quotes like this
one well you don't have a lot of hands
in smoking Iran we don't have
homosexuals like in your the night
religion however the ultimate concern
for Washington was the Iranian attempts
to build their own nuclear bomb
it's pretty scary to imagine the
possibilities when a government that
publicly declares their intention to
raise Israel from the map and whose
president denies the Holocaust as a
nearly
[Music]
further Iran hates Saudi Arabia and
other relationships that would be
complicated by Iran having the bomb
we're actually going to talk more about
the Iran Saudi Arabia relationship in an
upcoming video so being sure to
subscribe to this channel now if you
don't miss that and this is the moment
when America and Iran changed their
relationship status once again this time
that went from it's complicated to enemy
Security Council imposes sanctions on
Iran for failure to halt uranium
enrichment the Islamic Republic became a
real danger to international stability
these sanctions were no small thing
either
remember how Iran has the fourth largest
crude oil reserves in the world well the
economy of Iran unsurprisingly does rely
on these exports so imagine what would
happen when the wealthiest countries in
the world just stopped buying it January
Iranian government figure showed the
prices of bread milk and meat have risen
around 20%
well the price of chicken has jumped
about 80 percent since January Iranian
government figures showed the prices of
bread milk and meat have risen around 20
percent while the price of chicken has
jumped about 80 percent but do wait just
a second because oh yes the best is yet
to come the economic crisis destroyed
our committed against reputation and his
successor and current president Hassan
rouhani came to power under the promise
of liberal reforms and better
relationships with the west but this is
where things started to get very
interesting
the Arab Spring Iran is a Shia Islamic
country inside the Muslim world Shia
Islam is a minority this is one of the
reasons why the Iranian ayatollahs have
such a bad relationship with the Sunni
clergy in Saudi Arabia
[Music]
and this is the reason why Iran is
willing to do whatever they can to fight
- also known as Islamic state - is a
Sunni Muslim terrorist organization add
to this the fact that once America
removes its troops from Iraq the
ayatollahs funded the new government in
Baghdad and we can explain the following
Syria's President Bashar Assad says the
liberation of Aleppo from terrorists is
not only a victory for Damascus but also
results who participated in the fight
against terror
especially one in Russia the Iranian
army is fighting Islamic state both in
Syria and in Iraq and this is both a
help as well as a threat to the United
States no one wants to fight one radical
group just for it to be replaced with a
more radical one and yes this explains
why Obama had an interest in building
ties with Iran in fact it was a pretty
smart move since because he hits two
targets with one shot now on the one
hand Obama was sending a signal to Saudi
Arabia it was not willing to help in
fight - on that hand he is saying
whoever defeats the bad guys will have a
good relationship with the US more I
thought they would finally seal an
agreement with Iran in order to stop
their nuclear program and this is how
they close the famously controversial
Iranian nuclear deal under the nuclear
deal that we our allies and partners
reached with Iran last year Iran will
not get its hands on a nuclear bomb the
region the United States and the world
will be more secure
nonetheless Obama's successor Donald
Trump wants to stop this diplomatic
process even though the courts of vetoed
is infamous Islam banned the fact that
he included Iran on the list of
countries that cannot get into America
is a clear signal he is slamming the
door on Iran more importantly he is
showing some love for Saudi Arabia but
this is something we've covered in
another video and if you want to
understand why Donald Trump is such a
good friend of the Saudis click on this
video and now here is the big question
can America restore their relationship
with Iran is it worth it in order to
encourage Iran to be more moderate and
less radical you can leave your answer
this question in the comments below we'd
love to know about it and don't forget
that we publish brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday so please don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
any of those videos and if you like this
video do give it a thumbs up and as
always I'll see you next time
[Music]